okay so before we get to the questions
would you and the governor like to
answer what I was saying about it was
quoting Norm Ornstein and Thomas Mann
they're very very esteemed journalists
they were bipartisan and they said it's
the Republicans fault I think that when
President Trump has a good proposal the
country would be better off if Democrats
got behind like which one case in point
case in point
how long do you want to stay in
Afghanistan you're right that's the one
I'm hoping for and and there and and I
know one of the issues also that's there
is the deficit and if you bring the
troops back from these regime regime
changed wars that you would save
billions of dollars and lives yeah and I
think that's something that should have
the Republicans voted against him on
that they finally found something to
stand up to him about it was you are not
for war enough but but bill there is an
opportunity for a core of Democrats and
a core of Republicans to say you know
what the president's got a good point
here let's get behind him well I'm for
that I mean you're right the Liberals
have been hypocritical about that they
were for ending forever war and now
therefore and and and when he talked
about Family Medical Leave Chuck Schumer
stood up I think he was only one of the
Democrats side who did it but that you
know there again reward good behavior
the first step act to his credit cory
booker brought somebody who had been
released from jail who had been
sentencing for a long period of time and
that criminal justice reform in the
first step back passed in december great
partisanship and it should be done again
attacking opioids again great national
problem 60,000 people a year die from it
Democrats and Republicans have a good
opportunity to get behind something like
that when and then when he talks about
wiping out childhood leukemia why did
why not erupt with claps and applause
saying hell yeah let's do this because
it's a horrible I don't think that the
Democrats are for childhood leukemia
okay all right all right you got your
rebuttal in Governor Christie do you
think there are any Democrats that have
your signature in-your-face approach to
dealing with the opposition is there a
Democrat Chris Christie I guess they're
asking well god thank god no no I just
said I think Bernie has a bit of that
you know Bernie doesn't act out any and
when Bernie's got a point of view he's
gonna say it and he doesn't really
sugarcoat anything so I think Sandra's
is one of those who do you think is the
Democrats best choice to run in 2020 I
think the one that the president would
be most afraid of if he can stay in his
Lane is Biden and the reason why is
because Biden could go to Ohio and
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin and Michigan
and appeal to white working-class voters
and if he does that he only has to peel
off seven to ten thousand votes in each
one of those states to be and he's gonna
win two of them but there's many states
and he's not going to hurt the base
anyway see but well he's not going to
excite the base and but you know what
that base gets a little bit too excited
it's gonna drive away the rest of the
middle of the country because some of
the stuff that the base is talking about
is not gonna be you know it's not going
to be appealing to the middle of the
country and this is the same mistake I
think Democrats have made in a number of
different elections where they say this
is great we love it but they don't care
about what the middle of the country
thinks they care about the two coasts I
also put in Tulsi Gabbard and I put in
John Delaney if they get traction John
Delaney has an incredible business
record in Tulsi Gabbard I think she has
a refreshing voice when it comes to
these wars that are endless and regime
change she's pulling the Russians like
but that that investor the Russians like
her New York Times looked at that story
that NBC ran and discredited the guy who
claims that this guy named Jonathan
Morgan and a group called up okay Eric
Idle as president of the footlights Club
at Cambridge you were the first to allow
women to join you personally which I did
that yes you did what motivated your
decision
what year was that it was it was 1965
Wow and it was before the Cambridge
colleges admitted women and it was just
nuts you know what this funny women the
hell we need them in the club you know
sir and Germaine Greer was the first one
to join who wrote the she wrote the
Female Eunuch and and you had more balls
than any man but the pythons mostly
dressed as women
well that was personal reasons
[Laughter]
is it possible someday we will look back
on dressing as a woman and think that
that is not appropriate I mean we're
only at the beginning of really having
transgender awareness I wonder if some
day we'll look back and go WOW tutsi not
funny
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Tasha excluding Trump which family
member is more likely to be in jeopardy
with the special counsel Don junior or
Jared I think that Don junior is
probably in more immediate jeopardy just
because of his really congressional
testimony yeah I mean he has been
telling his friends and associates that
he expects to be indicted and he's been
saying that for the last couple months
so yeah I think that his his accounts
about you know the Trump Tower meeting
in 2016
his accounts about Trump Tower Moscow
and how involved he was and that could
put him in some legal jeopardy there and
as we know Muller has shown no shyness
about going after people for lying to
Congress so okay should any serious
discussion of the national debt by the
way in the in the State of the Union
speech no mention of that usually
presidents at least do lip service Trump
is like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna write a
check the whole time I'm here you know
what doesn't matter
printing money he said it I
any serious discussion of the national
debt include cuts to the military budget
yes yes to really cut it you got to talk
about everything and yes part of it you
got to talk about entitlements though to
which Democrats seems to be completely
allergic to you know they don't want to
talk about that well they don't want to
talk about I agree the fact that
Medicare and Medicaid I was a governor I
asked to do managed care and Medicaid
now this is not like splitting the atom
there's managed care everywhere where I
took the Obama administration
two-and-a-half years to give me
permission to spend the 50% that I spend
on managed care like Democratic
administrations have been allergic to
ever saying to anybody no you can't do
that in the entitlements so I agree with
you
I'll put military on this on the table
you put entitlements on the table and
we'll fix the brothers called a grand
bargain right and Obama tried for a
grand bargain with John Boehner and to
the point of the editorial I just did
the Republicans wouldn't let him
there wasn't remember that grand bargain
and a grand bargain is what we need but
it has to be giving up on both sides
Trump completely does not understand
this his way of negotiating is I want my
wall now how about you give me my wall I
spent eight years with Democrats in the
legislature New Jersey and what you
learn is everybody has to win if I'm
gonna negotiate
everybody has to win something and and
guys then awash you could have forgotten
about that it's because they don't have
to work with each other because they're
in these gerrymandered districts where
they never have to worry about a general
election all they have to worry about is
primaries in New Jersey I'm a Republican
I had to worry about my back every day
right so make deals and give them some
of what they watch that you get some of
what you want just remember he did in
February 2018 Schumer shut down the
government it was a three-day shutdown
over though thank you making a deal and
now all he's saying is why don't you
vote the way you did in February and we
we don't have any glitches in the
government he's only talking about five
point seven billion dollars and talking
about the military we all know that's
lunch money that's nothing five point
seven billion dollars in a three point
seven trillion
we when you add about what I'm saying
that same 5.7 billion in comparison yes
there are the things we spray on it
doesn't mean we should waste it on
something stupid
well yes Democrats 100 miles give the
wall 100 miles come back in two years
see which one's more effective and then
build build more of that or less like a
stealth wall because I think stealth
airplanes are literally invisible thank
you very much sleep tight
you